leute gebt euch das hier komme der käse
[Musik]
ausgedacht und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video ja ich hoffe natürlich
geht es gut ich weiß etwas andere
umstände heute
wir haben kein kameramann juli ist im
urlaub
ja deswegen bleibt mir nichts anderes
übrig gerade als das video so
aufzunehmen die früher halt geht auch ne
ist natürlich nicht ganz so cool ich
weiß aber ich gebe mir trotzdem mühe
das ist ein cooles video wird wir haben
aber auf jeden fall heute wieder extrem
coole sachen vor ich habe drei oder vier
tik tok live-acts rausgesucht nicht
normale live hacks es geht um essen
der letzte teil gegen ja auch schon am
essen also ich teste virale tik tok
essens live hacks da gibt's alles
möglich wirklich habe wieder so geile
sachen rausgesucht und ich würde sagen
wir man gar nicht lange starten direkt
mal mit dem ersten block kommt auf
weitere teile das ist nur nach oben da
ach so und ich wollte auch sagen sorry
das gestern kein video kam
ich habe es leider nicht geschafft ich
idiot ich habe euch auch im letzten teil
bereits ein live gezeigt den ich gerne
in diesem part testen möchte das letzte
video war schon zu lang deswegen dass
wir starten heute mit folgenden der
sieht so aus
leider ohne scheiß das tier so lecker
aus ich weiß noch früher ich habe mir
selber mal weil ich das gefeiert
herausgekommen ist ich wollte immer
selber zu hause total lustig machen habe
ich mal so versucht im toaster und so so
richtig geklappt hat es eigentlich nie
also eigentlich überhaupt nicht ich bin
gerade von meinem haus wieder nach köln
gefahren über die autobahn und dachte
mir an der tankstelle du brauchst auch
nutella und die hatten kein hotel
deswegen habe ich nur talgo genommen
nutella to go and go was auch immer
jetzt halt auch mitteilerin ist es egal
ich würde sagen das wird schon auf die
block hemd damit begleite ich heute das
ganze bisschen weg aber es wird trotzdem
rust und ab in die küche wo heute wir
brauchen nutella ein bisschen toastbrot
das hier ist jetzt vollkorn ich es immer
voll können weil das einfach ja so ein
bisschen gesünder ist glaube ich habe es
auch kein anderes hier aber das sollte
auch funktionieren dann hier dieses
pizza holding um das toastbrot von den
kanten zu trennen das klappte gut sechs
frische bio eier von denen wir gleich
auch noch mehr brauchen und eine fahne
ja das reicht doch eigentlich schon da
und action jetzt kommt ein bisschen
butter in die pfanne
ich starte jetzt erstmal mit zwei toast
brot also vier brauche ich eigentlich
nicht das reicht mir wir müssen ja auch
nur schauen ob es überhaupt
funktionieren kann und das hat mich so
ohne kameramann ist es echt schwer auf
jeden fall trennen wir jetzt die ecken
wie gut das geht ja die ecken und kanten
ab vom toastbrot und dann haben wir hier
ein richtig exzellentes quadra und weil
wir nichts wegschmeißen essen dann
brauchen wir ein bisschen keller da
können wir auch einen auf diese sticks
hier verwenden wir nehmen ganz viel
okay das war jetzt nicht so viel und
streichen dass hier die frauen nicht
abgebrochen
[Musik]
ok ich würde sagen das reicht auch schon
das muss ich jetzt zusammenreimen
ich gebe mir das muss perfekt klappen
wir nehmen das toastbrot und rollen ist
zusammen
ja vielleicht hätte ich die nutella
direkt am anfang platzieren sollen
doch nein es ist mein kollege schon
dreckig also sieht jetzt nicht ganz so
perfekt aus wie im video aber wir
brauchen jetzt die eier zum platzen
bringen das kann ich okay hier noch mal
von oben das anrühren und hier haben wir
meine prachtexemplare ja irgendwie sieht
das nicht so gut aus nehmen aber leute
gleich werdet ihr sehen das wird absolut
krank und jetzt nehmen wir diese teile
und rollen die einmal kommt ja wohl geld
und noch mal ja ab mit ihr und noch das
zweite bahn
das ist echt schwierig mit einer hand
irgendwie muss ich aufpassen dass ich
gerade kein rührei machen
vielleicht war das ein bisschen zu viel
ein alter mache ich gerade irgendetwas
falsch sollte wir sind einfach gleich
wieder wenn die länger fertig sind ja
wenn es schlecht wird liegt ganz klar
ein toastbrot nicht an mir
kleiner nachtrag leute ich habe auf
jeden fall alles richtig gemacht diesen
niebels nice aus ich freue mich jetzt
leicht zu probieren
ich bin noch nicht so ganz überzeugt
nutella und habe ich noch nie probiert
vorher aber wird schon schmecken
okay leute ohne scheiß ich bin so
gespannt es sieht jetzt sogar echt gut
aus ich zeige es euch mal hier ich habe
jetzt zwei stück gemacht dass mit dem
zucker und zimt sparen wir uns jetzt mal
liegt aber auch daran weil ich gerade
keinen sinn hier habe erst recht auf
jeden fall echt lecker und wenn das
jetzt schmecken sollte dann weiß ich
dass ich mir das öfter morgens zum
frühstück machen werde einfach weil es
auch extrem schnell gegen das hat jetzt
vielleicht so fünf bis sieben minuten
gedauert
jahrhundert euch nicht hier bisschen
hotel angekommen das passiert mir immer
okay schneidet das hier erst mal durch
ich bin echt gespannt 3 2 1 das ist echt
gut und richtig war
leute also das ist wirklich extrem
lecker empfehle ich euch macht das gerne
zu hause nach ich habe nur gerade
überlegt ob es wirklich so sinnvoll ist
da noch mit bei zu tun weil ich meine
wenn man einfach ein bisschen butter
nehmen würde
das wäre glaube ich schon besser weil
meiner meinung nach passt das aber nicht
wirklich zu
aber es hat auch noch meinen geschmack
sonst wirklich extrem lecker vor anderen
auch mit dem zimt und zucker dazu ist
sehr ungesund aber wen juckt es kommt
zum nächsten live leute ich wusste nicht
dass es so was gibt dann ist das so
funktioniert das ist extrem hilfreich
ich hab nämlich vor zweieinhalb stunden
extrem pizza hingestellt und die stehen
lassen
einfach so weil ich das halt brauche
pfizer die längere zeit raum steht und
wie man aus dieser abgestandenen pizza
eigentlich so kalte pizza schmeckt auch
geil ich weiß aber noch besser schmeckt
wenn sie frisch ist und wie man diese
pizza wieder frisch bekommt das schauen
wir uns jetzt machen wir jedes pc okay
leute da bin ich mir ein bisschen
unsicher ob sie nicht vielleicht von
unten an brennt wenn die da so lange
drin ist keine ahnung wir probieren es
natürlich wir brauchen nur wasser dieses
stück pizza und das war es auch schon
let's go aber erstmal eine studie von
okay leute um das jetzt zu testen
brauchen wir natürlich eine alte pizza
und die habe ich hier ja otte ich denke
das ist ziemlich leicht zu erkennen dass
diese pizza schon ein bisschen älter ist
die ist auch kalt die liegt jetzt
ungefähr so seit dreieinhalb schon also
mit frisch hat das überhaupt nichts mehr
zu tun
ich würde sagen wir testen das jetzt mal
die wieder frisch zu machen und dafür
brauche ich halt einfach die fahne und
ein bisschen wasser das war es auch
schon aber erstmal sollte ich mir
vielleicht ein kleines stück
herausschneiden so dass sie ganz gut aus
so normal großes stück und das kommt
jetzt in die pfanne
ich habe jetzt mal so auch mittlere
stufe gestellt ich glaube das war im
video auch so zac ja meinen damit und
jetzt brauchen wir wasser ich hoffe ich
habe jetzt nicht zuviel genommen ich
mache jetzt mal keine habe darüber
einfach damit ich das noch ein bisschen
beobachten kann
solche eigentlich trotzdem gehen ok dann
würde ich sagen das sollte eigentlich
reichen wird auf jeden fall schon ein
bißchen besser aus als vorher ich weiß
nicht ob das jetzt genauso gut wie im
video geklappt hat aber wir probieren
jetzt mal leute wir haben hier jetzt
einmal ein altes stück ja sieht bank ich
zeige es euch mal eben also das hier ist
die alte und das hier ist die frische da
erkennt man ja ganz klar ein unterschied
ich probiere jetzt einmal die alte
vielleicht auch gut aber heute ist
übrigens nicht angebrannt also die neue
so sieht die neue aus und so die alte
also irgendwie sieht die sogar besser
aus von unten und man kann ja auch ganz
klar erkennen dass die vielflieger ist
falls es das richtige wort ist als diese
hier also hier geht ja gar nix sie haben
schmeckt wie neu leuchtet mégane 1live
weg auf jeden fall bestanden kein fake
macht es nach herzlich willkommen zurück
ein habe ich noch und das ist der den
ich am nächsten tag schon gezeigt habe
ich habe keine ahnung wie man das nennt
ist so eine art komplett mit bacon käse
eiern gut ist ja klar
und noch ein theater also diese
vorgefertigten form
wir schauen noch mal ganz kurz rein
geschäftsführer der insel barbados dr
also das ist schon extrem geil mir ist
schon als das beim letzten mal gesehen
hab wirklich das wasser im mund
zusammengelaufen
ich bin zwar kein guter koch ich weiß
ich habe schon immer gesagt ich will mal
so ein crashkurs machen aber ich bin mir
sicher das werde ich trotzdem gut
hinbekommen und ich würde sagen ab in
die küche ist okay leute kommen wir zum
letzten live weg und auch auf jeden fall
zum schwersten ich hoffe es klappt ich
habe das alles schon vorbereitet also
nur das eine
dann brauchen wir noch dann braucht ihr
noch salz und pfeffer salz pfeffer und
hier habe ich noch pakete bacon ganz
wichtig und diese tortilla dinger acht
stück all das kann ich alles machen
chiesa diaz werden das was auch immer
die tasse daran hat okay let's go
erstmal brauchen wir natürlich eigelb ja
okay das geht schnell sagt das sind drei
eier wie im video und ab damit in die
pfanne
mehr mehr mehr scheiße ja perfekt jetzt
wir brauchen ein bisschen salz und ein
bisschen pfeffer
das ist also schnell egal okay das sieht
schon ganz gut aus und das tote tier
dingen oben drüber
das jetzt hoffentlich das schön aufnimmt
okay ich habe keine ahnung ob ich
perfekt gemacht habe lass mich mal
machen dann zeige ich euch gleich das
endresultat
ja geil okay leute ich habe das jetzt
gerade gewendet jetzt brauchen wir ein
bisschen käse habe ich bin käse freund
alter ich mache einfach ein bisschen
mehr und jetzt natürlich noch den bacon
den hätte ich vielleicht vor anbraten
sollen ein braun ich ein bisschen welk
kann muss sein dann geht das leben von
ganz allein
ich weiß ich kann nicht singen und
kochen
ich bin gerade überlegen ich nehme mir
auch ein bisschen ein bisschen gouda
käse noch dazu dann haben wir allen käse
und dunklem käse borders könnte auf
jeden fall leicht aussehen weil weil das
ist mir noch nicht genug der bacon ist
jetzt zwischen den zwei verschiedenen
käsesorten einer kranken geht euch mal
kurz so sieht's jetzt aus das muss ich
jetzt ganz schnell wenden und dann hoffe
ich dass es klappt ihr könnt euch nicht
vorstellen wie anstrengend das ist oder
jemanden zu haben der das ganze mit der
kamera begleitet sagt ja komm komm komm
komm ja also gut aussehen tut es auf
jeden fall es ist ein bisschen knusprig
geworden aber ich muss sagen das macht
mir auf jeden fall eine menge spaß und
das ist ja das wichtigste ich heiße auch
ticket übrigens alex flops alex können
sie mir sehr gerne folgen
das riecht gut ich würde sagen es reicht
jetzt aber auch na also leute das ist
das endresultat sieht ein bisschen aus
wie crêpes ist es aber nicht
ja und dieser sich gern noch mal ich
schneide das jetzt mal durch und dann
schauen wir mal wie das aussieht war
leute gebt euch das hier komme der käse
also ich bin auf jeden fall alter sehr
zufrieden
ich würde sagen dann lass dich nicht
schmecken
[Musik]
ich muss jetzt sagen ist ein bisschen
salzig geworden aber trotzdem lecker ja
echt geil
man schmeckt auch gegentreffer haben wir
vielleicht augen bestimmt trotzdem geil
also auch der funktioniert heute hat
alles geklappt ich hoffe es hat euch
gefallen
wir sehen uns jetzt noch mal bastel und
ihr könnt mir sehr gerne irgendwelche
ticker live acts zu senden
die ich mal ausprobieren sollten ob sie
funktioniert oder nicht ja heute ich
würde sagen das waren auf jeden fall
drei kranke live hacks abonniert den
kanal abonniert auch mein zweiter kanal
reaction kanal ist ganz oben in der
besteuerung verlinkt für weitere patzer
von lasse nach oben da und wir sehen uns
dann morgen um 10 uhr wieder gibt's
neues video mehr wo ich auch gar nicht
sagen das war's instagram alex w
haut rein und ich habe hier immer noch
was rum liegen das ist ohne scheiß das
beste das es sogar
[Musik]